back on the hasso's
so that one was
iski and this next one is
hasagaishushiroski
before i demonstrate it
i've been bringing up one particular
point
before
must be 40 years now
heaven knows how many times i must have
said it around the world the differences
nobody seems to realize the importance
of it
but if you don't understand this
you won't understand this hasso
okay
it's the lining up
if you don't do this with the finger
check yourself all the time at the end
of your strikes when you're holding the
joe when you're cutting with the ken try
to keep it
closed in more cytosense used to say
you know if that sticks out it's an
object for somebody to notice and
and break it with their jaw or ken
i have seen him with his finger a little
bit like that but
it's a case of uh do what your master
tells you
right so try and keep there you don't
want
this cut wrist with this
gap here wants to be flat
so there's no there's no there's no gaps
it wants to be there it wants to be
exact at right angles
exactly
most people hold it here they hold it
here
they just don't seem to understand there
and when they hold it
they got this gap when they think
they've got it right they still got this
gap
it's got to be flat as if my arm
is part of that joe lying on it
if not you'll never understand this and
you'll always be doing it
with your strength doesn't matter
whether you're male
female you know trans it doesn't matter
if you're a human being
it needs to be part of the joe
okay so i'll show it from the rear first
it connects it settles
but it doesn't settle it only settles as
far as
on your body you go to the end of the
jar
it it's like a spiral
like a spiraling bowel
okay
this is like striking with a hammer you
can imagine
a hammer ammo blower
your posture is
in the type posture
trigger type posture
so
make your body your head all this
movement
fluid flowing together
whatever the footwork whatever the
the hasso
do it slowly pay attention to what your
body's doing
speed will come naturally you don't have
to put speed
in
speed will come naturally you can always
make these packages
uh look better by staying with your zan
chin
all right you can
do lots of modifications
you may find lots more that you can
develop yourself
look turn the body slowly from the hips
as you reach out
i say to all my students also you should
do yoga
because uh you need to learn flexibility
you know we're stretching our arm at
great length
at the same time as turning the body
you're going in two different directions
expression of hands turning
lots of beautiful things in this
foreign
[Music]
if you don't look first how would you
know if your enemies moved what about
they move
a little bit like you know is for
multiple attack
so you need to check
you can then move
you can move to where they are before
you release
too many people get so involved in the
enjoyment of doing it
they don't look and they just ski in the
same robotic place
every single time that's not what aikido
is about
if you do it together look this happens
as well
the joe goes offline
the joe goes offline you're stiff you're
stuck
turn where are they
ski to where they are or
try different angles you know imagine
that you're being surrounded by
many opponents and you choose different
points that you you use your skin
huh
always come back to keyhole
no gaps look fast
this way for a strike
to settle or
you'll change your hands
you can do lots of different things with
the joe it doesn't have a blade it
doesn't have a handle
doesn't have an end so you can
experiment with them
i encourage you to do so
as long as it feels right and it's safe
in budo that means marshall you're not
just
twiddling a piece of wood around having
fun as long as it's doing something in a
marshall way
then you're you're safe thank you for
your time
and we'll carry on with the the next uh
passive guys
don't want to understand